major news story out of pop culture
beyonce is changing the lyrics to her
song he did
haven't listened to the song haven't
listened to the album
she's changing the lyrics
because she uses an ableist
term
that
some people are saying is very offensive
to the handicapped community and so
beyonce has come out and she said okay
i'm going to change the word
to the song i have not listened to the
song i've just printed out the lyrics
here i'm just going to read you one
stanza from the song
you tell me what's wrong with this
stanza
never met a girl so fine like this no no
no no no fan me off i'm hot hot hot with
a waste that whine like this y-w-h-i-n-e
tip-tip on tip on hardwood floors 10 10
10 across the board with a waist that
whine like this give me face face face
face face yeah
your face card never declines
eat it eat it eat it eat it eat it
yummy yummy yum make the bummy heated
make a pretty girl talk s-h-i-t-t-y
whiskey till i'm tipsy glitter on my
kitty ooh cool it down down down my
pretty
bad bad b-i-t-c-h-e
make that bad b-i-t-c-h glitchy fine
fine fine fine fine fine fine liberated
living like we ain't got time yada yada
yada ya
i'm not saying that that's actually in
the lyrics
spasm on that ass spasm on that ass
fan me quick girl i need my glass fan me
off my wrist goes click dimples on my
hip stretch marks on my tits drink in my
water mind in my biz
monday i'm overrated tuesday on my dick
and and then it actually somehow sort of
gets worse i'll just leave it there
the reason that she has to change the
words is because of the word spazz
everything else is totally fine the
problem with the song is the word spazz
and they're saying it's ableist which is
ridiculous because obviously whoever
wrote this song is extremely mentally
deficient so i don't see how in any way
this could be called ableist but that's
the word you're not allowed to use that
word spazz this is apparently offensive
to
some disabled people
so the song will have that word changed
it will remain
absolute degenerate filth
but that one word is going to be
switched out
what a sad
statement on
our culture that's what's wrong with the
song
that's how is this even a song i don't
know how you could even call this a song
very very sad that we are living in in
that culture
very very that's it don't you think it's
a little misogynistic by the way not to
sound like a lib don't you think it's a
little offensive to women treating women
just like sex objects or men like sex
objects don't you think it's a little
vulgar and obscene and just no
it's just that it's
offensive to [ __ ] people
how do you get to a culture like this
how do you how do you get to a culture
like he did
like like whatever beyonce is singing
about
part of it is just something in the air
something in the water something in the
zeitgeist but a lot of this is from
politics a lot of this is from the law
the law is a teacher okay and
the sexual revolution
was not just a cause of the changes in
law the law the changes in law was a
cause of the sexual revolution as well
okay and so if if conservatives want to
uh
want to change more of these lyrics not
just the ableist lyrics but all of them
if we want to get back to a culture that
is not just so degraded and treats
people like absolute
animals and starts treating people like
people again and it actually has some
beauty to it and poetry and lifts our
eyes up a little bit beyond just the
things that are flapping and dabbing and
yaya ya on the floor with the face-face
face if if we want to have a culture
that is edifying and flourishing we've
got to take on this issue the libs
always say why are conservatives so
obsessed with sex we're the ones
obsessed with sex you're the ones
pushing this crap you're the ones
pushing all these laws and grooming the
kids and putting sex everywhere in the
culture you're the ones doing that
because you know that it is so extremely
effective at
pulling out people's
lowest basest appetites
you know it's so central to human nature
you know it's it is so influential on
political society maybe we need to start
wielding political power
in the opposite way that the libs did
for the last century to try to restore a
more normal culture otherwise we're
going to be
spazzing and flapping and yapping and
doing all sorts of stuff and that that
will not be good for anybody i'm glad
you like that cliff folks we hit
a million subscribers on the youtube
channel we did that pretty much
two days before my second baby boy was
born into this world it's a good week is
what i'm saying now let's turn it up a
notch let's take that 1 million
subscribers let's make it 1 billion i
want 1 billion youtube subscribers
please ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]